what is going on there reject nation
welcome to the space jam
you feel fine all right yeah
i believe i can fly i'm gonna touch the
sky touch the sky
everyone loves r kelly these days
because we're gonna watch space jamming
new legacy today it is available on hbo
max if you want to do a stream along
with us full length watch longs are over
at our patreon over there we cover a
whole bunch of other shows with the same
tier you get the option
for reaction highlights and watch along
included and everyone who joins
especially for the
ones that come out on hbo max really
appreciate it because uh odds are this
will not be monetized especially because
of
all the songs that are probably featured
in here oh that ip but if you guys end
up enjoying our reaction please go ahead
and hit that like button and if you want
to see more from us
subscribe and click that notification
bell lastly got to thank for thumb jin
doll for editing these highlights for us
uh you are a hustler baby stick around
to see what our opinions are
after the reaction is done let's get to
it
[Music]
all right my ship's not over till nine
so tell coach c i'm gonna be a few
minutes late picking you up okay
good luck out there today hey brian you
forgetting something
love mom james
what's up brian summerlin my dad got me
to do colorway
cool ah i still have mine
oh collect them carrots
hey man the blonde would have actually
been good at basketball if he didn't
play so much game boy
[Music]
it's a damn game boy you could be a
once-in-a-generation
talent if you focus on the game of
basketball
and not these distractions you got the
chance to use basketball to change
everything for your mom for you for
everybody who you care about
to become so literal soon yeah you know
little did he know though he should have
kept the game boy
cleveland cavaliers select lebron
james emmy nominated don
cheadle hopefully he'll get a best lead
actor nomination at the oscars for this
i like the animation effects that
brought her yeah it's a nice way to jump
you back in without just going straight
to looney tunes we're not
just shut up and dribble
and a cool way to replicate the michael
jordan montage from the first one
see if he can back it up all right don't
get crossed
[Music]
what was that you piece of [ __ ] here
you got a video game i better not find a
video game here
everything in between these four lines
has worked who said i wasn't working
this thing right here and then i'll
cross over step back
come on dom you got to concentrate god
tom you're a failure
you know cross over step back shoot
yep see that's cause your brother been
putting in that work i ball all day
you got a basketball camp next weekend
boys gonna be coming at your neck
seeing what you got my reputation's on
the line
my career right so your camp he's 12 and
he built his own game
a lot of distractions he doesn't need a
coach he needs his dad
that was that's the lie dude
that might be the theme of this movie i
think there's a lot of things
established
marketing oh hey
i drive past here all the time
it's like a water brothers 3d simulator
yeah i can't wait to ride this at the
studio tour
the server verse oh my god
do you think the snyder cut exists in
here too it's all there
including the green lantern footage it's
there algorithmically speaking he's more
than an athlete
he's a king king
lebron just look at this guy pete once
i've partnered with king james
and combine his fame with my
incredible tech
i will finally get the recognition and
respect that i so
richly deserve
that whole scene was longer than what he
got nominated for at the end
yeah he's gonna get that oscar nod for
that
you're wasting your time go dribble
work on that layup stop learning how
computers work
i still have to figure out some of the
player designs nice
posterize posterize it's like basketball
but better remember fun that
i am fun in and out crossover
step back let it go
oh no no don't erase my character
hey i think i got something that'll
cheer you up i'm meeting out warner
brothers about some high-tech movie
thing
you should come please dad dad
no i said please
[Laughter]
ah scoob the matrix teen titans they're
just posters
they're easter eggs here at warner
brothers
space jam but now
it's time for our greatest creation yet
warner 3000 our brand new warner 3000
technology will scan you right into the
movies
think about it batman versus lebron
lebron of thrones oh no
i mean look at him look at that face
he's speechless he he loves it
listen guys i'm a ball player you know
and anthony's acting
that never goes well
this idea is just straight up bad
algorithm
is busted busted
it's among the worst ideas i've ever
heard top five easy
i'm actually building my own video game
you heard of the e3 game design camp
right
yeah yeah and i'm going there's going to
be a
how much you're looking for you can't go
to that basketball camp is next weekend
i'm not going to basketball camp dad
that's not what i want dad
can't just leave a warner brothers me no
he's going to go live with stephen
united's their silver
dom i'm connected to the father-son
relationship i'm not gonna you know why
i like it
right this way king james no you know i
can't let you back out of camp like that
you make me hate basketball
ouch you never let me do what i want to
do
streaming services
[Music]
we're in the computer we're in the
computer yeah
you know i'm claustrophobic
siri nothing to be afraid of
the computer's black i can see that
computers
you really shouldn't have rejected my
ideas back there now i'm afraid you're
gonna have to help me fulfill my destiny
[Laughter]
we're gonna play a game of basketball in
front of the largest captive audience
ever and when they see the two of us
together
and the entire world is going to know
the name of king algae rhythm
if you win you and your son can ski
daddle on out here
when you lose you're just gonna have to
stay here in the server verse with me
that is messed up dude you know you
think this is a game
i'm calling authorities on you because
what you got going on here this phone
how'd you do that
lebron why are you worried about the
authorities when you should be out there
looking for a team
send this clown to the rejects
join us
hey a little classic love
hey i want to change the theater songs
[Music]
they got to acknowledge the first space
jam movie absolutely
it's already it's already appeared once
what is this shorter than kevin hart
is this where the game is gonna happen
where is everybody
wait it's only what i got i guess right
now
question is who's left
i'm assuming it's just bugs
this looks authentically kind of 2d
animated this is beautiful
[Applause]
what's up doc
bucks bunny [ __ ]
i can't believe bring it in man
bring it in man smells funny man aren't
you
lebron james
pugs bunny knows who i am
i do not understand this world
[Laughter]
this is pretty funny he butted them up
saying they were wasting their time that
there was much more to see in a soybear
voice than old two world
made them point their backs on who they
really were
oh poor bugs that's terrible family's
everything
yep you want me
to play with you an nba superstar in a
high-stakes basketball game
sounds awfully familiar
but yeah that actually sums it up well i
think i know a way to can help to both
of us
that is so creative well it's my planet
[Music]
i think lebron does a really good job on
the voice over here yeah
yeah it seems like he's having fun with
it he's all lie
he hated this experience
come on let's boogie what you're selling
this [ __ ] i didn't agree to this
my ship basket rabbit
[Laughter]
oh
he's out there looking for a team a team
yeah
he challenged me to a basketball game oh
who built this
well someone brilliant
heard you visionary your own character
too yeah but he got deleted because of
some stupid glitch
what happened to the glitch oh i think
the glitch is
all part of the plan look what i found
oh bugs has got to hit an agenda oh
no
[Music]
oh no i was just asking you
ugh
hey what's that for doc we're gonna need
the most powerful warner brothers
characters for this team
now let's see gotta start with superman
man i could have used him on the cavs
oh king kong it'd be a beast on the
boards
we're gonna need a strong power forward
iron giant put him on the same team as
his hero superman
yes that trinity batman so how come you
stayed on tune world
where i belong is that harry potter
world
[Laughter]
oh
oh i'm glad someone's excited to be a
hufflepuff i can't wait to see what i
turn into here oh it's gonna be somebody
dope
hey yo yo
brought the animation style back for it
this has got to be the nicest surprise
about this movie so far
unless someone stops this thing it'll
crash straight into
orphanage
cool
no we're superman is it alfred in the
back there
that alfred yeah
yeah super bad come on uh we did it
oh no you don't rabbit i did this it was
me
i'm
but now we gotta crew up build our lease
squad so i can get my son back
and that's exactly what we'll do it's
draft day why don't you get michael
jordan
yeah and larry bird and charles barkley
oh my god
[Music]
what
oh my god
i know what you need you need a plan
yeah
[Laughter]
can we just get some players who are at
least tall enough to ride a roller
coaster
oh how cool he's your problem now dumb
dog
good morning
what's happening bro
[Music]
[Laughter]
but you got to give me at least one real
ballplayer bugs well i got just the
player you need a
true friend of the court ah here comes
oh i bet she's gonna look so sexy that's
right
you have earned the right to become one
of us
excuse me find me find me excuse me
excuse me pardon me
there she is they're all bad
we need your help we gotta play a
basketball game
i spent years training for this do not
mess it up for me i have to save my son
what lola cares
we need your help
heavens oh no i failed
a warrior is judged not only by her
skill
but by her values you are now
an amazon is that rosario dawson oh
maybe oh
god i'm so distracted by her redesign
not sexy enough too sexy which is but
it'll do for now
i can still use that imagery later
[Laughter]
i can get someone online to commission
me something much more ideal
just jokes people dad took me up with
some of his friends at a nba charity
event
i thought maybe they could help me with
the character designs for my game
[Laughter]
[Music]
stored all the scans right on my phone
this phone
so theoretically this applicator can
scan people in from anywhere in the
world
using their own phones yeah i guess that
is sick
it's really a shame that your dad
doesn't support you i mean
i get it he's one of the greatest of all
time at what he does well the jury's
still out on that i think but go ahead
i think i know a way we can fix this
we're gonna make your dad stand up
and take notice of you young prince
what
oh boy
do you guys not remember anything from
the first space jam movie guys come on
[Laughter]
no
this isn't real basketball you're right
but it's fun
you remember fine don't you die he
doesn't sound like that
that loser son of his yeah
suicide squad they advertise the suicide
squad coming out soon isn't it
you can become the player that your dad
always wanted you to be
there's a s disgusting story about
father
horrendous nature of unaccepting
turn um
that's it yes
ah yes let's max the character out
you really are captain of my basketball
[Music]
team
you said we were rebuilding my character
you never said anything about me
actually playing in the game dads don't
understand reason dom
they understand power you make him see
that you are special
i really like dodgy to look at this
movie that dad do too
he's got a full-on character here yeah
no he's your father
[Music]
whoa i got handles you got
mad handles there's no way we're gonna
get beat now
that's manipulative this is almost
shakespearean
guys guys dad just tweeted thank god
about what he said he's playing in a
game later today
it's some kind of epic live event that
you can stream on this app
now if he's tweeting from his phone
right now then that means i can track
him on my phone
that's what i was gonna say i think this
movie has a better handle on the family
stuff outside of the space jam world
yeah the first one yeah
right now it's all about dawn dom's all
about family
it's a shame they don't own any
universal preference
you already got what you wanted your
friends tune world i still need my son
back
outside these lines be as lonely as you
want but inside
you do what i say oh
he touched this that abusive
father is what he is oh no
uh-oh he's here
let the space jam begin begin
jabbing let us go to space
well if it isn't the old news looney
tunes
looking just as washed up as ever
[Music]
i think it's time for an upgrade
an upgrade
oh snap we're going 3d
whoa
what's happening
that looks so real it's the best effect
yet
let's get some butts in dc
easter eggs galore oh easter eggs galore
one giant iron butt
oh this whole team is here
right about buffering i hope i'm about
looking at the background the whole time
no teddy wise right there the duck
pennywise the joker somebody there
white walkers ice king
db cooper it's game time
oh where are we
it looks like that's game starting who's
this guy got some vips
coming in no
yeah what a twist
[Music]
hey what is going on where's dom i don't
know but i have to go play this game to
save everyone with bugs bunny
uh what's up dob
oh you know how to play it right it's
basketball
of course yeah excuse me you should have
paid a session cheers son
most of you can't even watch the game
from there i know
i better have one gigantic jumbotron
if king james wins you all get to go
back to your regular
boring lives if my team wins
you all get to stay with me in the
server verse
forever
[Laughter]
that wasn't the deal oh yeah didn't see
that coming did you
gotta read the terms of service all of
the tunes will be deleted so
what does she have against the tunes i
don't know
maybe he's just an ageist
wow and this next young man i'm bringing
out
y'all gonna love him he's my hero on the
ones and zeroes
mr dominic j
oh no
[Applause]
animation exit the background tower
you gotta win this game you gotta crush
his dreams
the lighting effects
this game is ridiculous top to bottom
bugs bunny gonna need a rabbit's foot
against this
enter in the splash what
style point is that style points
style points what is this college
football
out of my way you big worm
thank you
throws down a monster tongue wow
is this legal yeah she got six arms what
else she's supposed to do how is this
fair
cause video games
i've never seen anything like this
lebron's gonna are there no rules in
this game
gonna have to level up
wow wow
there's no rules it's rigged
this whole game's rigged
[Music]
two points let's go him and lola
we're gonna carry the team
what are you calling not you girl
it's so late to say that i
don't remember actually calling you that
oh i got this
lebron's on a mission he wants to go
coast to coast
[Music]
new character
[Applause]
what
oh no
[Applause]
back to the buckets
we need bill murray i don't know if this
counts as a miracle
but i found michael jordan be within the
audience
i know he can help really it's better to
be really
[Music]
michael b jordan the actor i was just
getting some popcorn and then his cat
grabbed me how could you think he was
his anus
they walked nothing alive did not sick
of it
it's the only thing that could have
worked
that's why ryan coogler produced this
movie that's right just to get him in
just getting him in here got him that
credit
i've been trying to save my son and
coach all at the same time what y'all
doing we've been trying
trying to do what trying to be like you
you're all his children he had learned
to let people be themselves
time to do what you guys do best
you did it lebron you saved the looney
tunes
back in action lebron
tunes are coming back out here for the
third quarter with some renewed energy
and i don't understand why
they are losing really badly
[Laughter]
a thousand two points ahead
smart yeah
no wait wait i wasn't i wasn't trying to
start it oh no
hey porky fryer
[Music]
this is like not a basketball game
oh oh boy here goes
[Laughter]
[Music]
egg that's the bacon right there
what game did your son invent
how could you possibly play this even on
like a pc
what rules exist to govern this game or
is it just whoever's done scoring
by the allotted time and just like that
the tunes have a
thousand points on the board you having
fun yet
games aren't about fun
[Music]
what
[Laughter]
senior discount
[Music]
yeah that's right
oh yeah the other move the lullaby did
[Applause]
[ __ ] mountain's finest
here we go dude i don't even care if we
make it back to the real world
they got everyone in costume just to be
like
[Music]
time maybe your dad was right about you
letting you be you was a mistake oh
oh don cheadle it's taking your emmy
nomination away
then we could all sit on the bench
[Laughter]
iso
[Music]
dad what are you doing in the middle of
a game your game is amazing son
but i guess i would have known that if
i'll listen more sorry i did
i want you to be yourself do you
understand how much i love you
do you understand how important you are
to me uh-huh
i don't even know if i'm saying this
right sounds right to me
i love your dad oh now
that's beautiful i think you want people
to fear you more than anything
and i'm not about that algae i made this
just in case thanks brady what's up dog
go ahead dom because it's not your game
anymore
i am the gang king kong
ain't got nothing on me
oh my oh no
uh play some d
monster but we bout to break the
internet baby
so creepy remember the step back glitch
in and out crossover step back shoot
that move froze my whole game
the game crashes lg won't be able to
control it anymore
and if he can't control it he can't stop
us from scoring
when my character did the step back he
got deleted
fo whoever dove the glitch move
will get deleted pepe le pew has to do
it
oh no is bugs going to do it i'm going
to do the step back
what no dad you'll be deleted not a
video game character
lebron you don't have to do this no no
let's
just give me the ball tool squad on
three one two
three two tune squad
[ __ ] just gonna do it i can feel it say
it ain't so
ten seconds on the clock one style point
play away from victory or defeat
[Applause]
last chance what are you doing
in and out crossover
[Music]
bugs bugs bunny now we'll never remember
him
bug shot is gonna be short
[Music]
but wait lebron is flying through the
air
seth had been at least 10 seconds
do the long arm one more
regular arm the regular arm
did it lebron you saved the warner
brothers archive
[Laughter]
i love you
destroyed the servers forever by taking
care of the people you love
is fun to mention thank you
fundamentals save lives goodbye braun
[Music]
hbo hmm is restored
we can go on watching a wabbit
no why is he still glitching that's all
folks no what
what are you doing no
jesus bugs you can't
do that to bugs
so but you ready for the basketball camp
look
you didn't know where they were driving
oh smartest kid i've ever known
he was driving he doesn't spend any time
outside you know he's never seen a map
thank you dad you're welcome hey man
have fun hold on to the basketball
i think i'm gonna hold on to it bus
[Laughter]
not a scary movie
[Laughter]
hey bugs what's bugs doing here
i told you i'm a tune doc i can survive
anything it's good logic
you did it space jam
i'll rewrite history from here on out
million dollar granny nowadays anyone
can kick ronda rousey test
yeah she doesn't have any of her looney
tunes powers in that fight it's just
still beating ronda rousey
how has our real world been affected by
this not
much you know a few thousand people were
were displaced for a couple of hours but
otherwise you know
experience the blip i hope that they
make i picture them in this suit so i
was like i could do a men in black with
lebron james and bugs bunny
yeah all right so we just watched that
[Laughter]
i don't think we're gonna talk for too
long i know i said that every time and
we end up talking for like 20 or 30
minutes but i feel like we can keep this
one pretty short
fairly short uh yeah i mean
i enjoyed it i didn't dislike it you
know i think um
i think just from expectation standpoint
and then seeing
all the you know negative criticism it
was receiving from critics
it about set my expectations at the
right
pitch so there was nothing here that
i was like mad about
i don't know there's a lot of cynicism
that seems to be surrounding this movie
of it being like the hbo max warner
brothers advertisement film
right which yeah i don't blame people
for feeling that way
and i mean to me i'm like sure it's
there
but at the same time i i was there there
were plenty of moments especially in the
first half when they are hopping around
to the different warner brothers moments
that i thought were like
really cool i thought it was cool when
you were looking at the when they go
into like the dc world
and it's like oh they brought the
animation back they animated them
exactly like how i remembered when i was
a kid
uh i thought that was great you know
they have some fun
with with the with all the hopping
around [ __ ] that they were doing
and i thought that they did a pretty
good job on the father-son
story like that i guess what if anything
surprised me
was i wasn't expecting to be emotionally
endeared towards the lebron and sun
storyline
and i wasn't expecting to have as many
genuine laughs as i did when i was
watching this
and i also wasn't expect the third thing
i would say is that i thought don
cheadle would be annoying and i didn't
find him annoying
and so to me overall there's a win there
are some things that i definitely
did not like about it but overall i
thought it was cute and it was fun
and i i don't know i don't i don't feel
the the the cynic in me surprisingly did
not come out when watching this
i feel like i would be likely to go
there but
surprisingly didn't feel cynical about
their ip
promotional stuff that they were doing
and because
it seemed like they had even though
there's like six riders here
it didn't feel as much of like uh
it like it didn't lack direction in what
it was doing i felt like the director
still knew what he was
making and so due to that
like all right whatever was fine it
wasn't uh i didn't think it was terrible
and uh i i surprisingly enjoyed it more
than i
thought i would uh not great there are
some things that
i could talk about but yeah john yeah
it's not necessarily
like high art or or cinema but yeah it's
about what i
expected a space jam sequel to be and
for
that i feel like it could have been way
more annoying or way more
uh you know lurid in its attempts to
appeal
to the here and now like i i liked
that it did kind of revel in some of the
looney tunes-ness of all this and yeah
split the difference
uh with at least a genuine quality
with the you know actual father-son
family dynamic
like there's something about this yeah
that i could see
like it's it's it's kind of exactly you
just put it the right way it's like
nothing here made me mad
it's about what i expected the first
space jam was
literally came out because it was based
on a commercial
and so like expecting this to be a
commercial weirdly they didn't go
into the other realms of hbo and
wb owned properties as much as
like it's funny it became a distraction
to me
part way through the movie only because
it was like i feel like
you got a bunch of extras to dress up
like some of the wb characters and
that's kind of the most
presence they have minus a couple of
like parodies and stuff
so yeah like i feel like that's kind of
the biggest hindrance on the movie but
when it's just doing you know
looney tunes animation jumping around
between the different worlds and
iterations
i was having like way more fun with it
and really
enjoying it for what it was doing more
than i expected to
and then when it gets to the basketball
like the first part of the basketball
game
i didn't find that enjoyable but i also
don't mind that because that's part of
the plot
so like they're supposed to kind of
loosen up and get wild and then it gets
more fun
so yeah i mean they actually gave a
character arc to lebron james
i thought they cared a little bit more
than i was expecting them to care
in terms of doing some stuff because you
know that's what i i like the first
space jam movie
i don't think it's a great film i don't
even think
it's that good of a film necessarily but
i i
like it because i grew up on it yeah and
uh
there's some really enjoyable stuff and
there's some funny stuff to look at when
you when you go back and watch it of how
michael jordan doesn't really seem to
give a [ __ ] about his family that
doesn't really seem to matter like at
all to him he just wants to get back and
play basketball
and not that lebron james is by any
stretch like
a damn good actor or something but there
are times where
i i was actually really impressed with
his voiceover work when he was a tuned
character
i felt like that's when he seemed to
show the most like
range with having some fun and uh i
didn't think he was
distractingly bad at any moment like
does he reach the caliber of like oh
this guy should star in more movies
no i never really quite got there with
him but
i think he did a better performance than
michael jordan did in the first one
yeah and there's something about the
limitations maybe in the acting
especially for the lead character that
that adds to the charm and yeah it's
like lebron james clearly committed he's
clearly having fun with this and yeah
there are certain moments that are
maybe a little bit wooden but i kind of
expect that of space jam as well
you know he calls it out flat out saying
you know like lebron james they have
that meadow joke
yeah it never goes well when you put an
athlete as a star of a movie yeah
they're making fun of that fact
so they're not even setting the bar high
in terms of expectations for
it but i don't think i would have been
endeared to the performance
to the story of the father and son if he
wasn't doing a passable
job to say the least yeah absolutely you
know what i mean yeah so
for an athlete starring in a movie and
it's just a space jam sequel
they did a fine job like uh you know i
don't i don't
i don't think it's uh anything terrible
here of what he did
i do think that the um in the back and
the basketball game
well i think what what it is it's it's
starting to come to me right now
what was throwing me for a loop because
like
yes the first space it's hard to
describe because i could be like there's
no rules here and some of it doesn't
make any sense you're like well it's
gonna like the first one right
if you haven't seen this movie and you
say that people might immediately just
go well it sounds like you're describing
the first space jam
sure i think though what made it muddied
was how you can make so many points
that are not connected to putting a ball
through the hoop
yeah video game like it makes sense but
it also does take away from the
basketball
tension yeah it's not even a space
basketball game they call it space champ
too
but like i don't really give a [ __ ] that
they're not in space fighting
uh but it's not a space basketball game
and
server jam yeah and i think that's what
it was when i'm like okay there there's
it's such a it's it became a little too
wild for me when it i think it would
have helped just
focus it a tad bit was the only way to
get points really
was by making the ball in the hoop that
way it still feels like a basketball
game like you can see all your weird set
pieces you can still
do all your breaking away in a rap game
rap battles and whatever do all that
like wacky [ __ ]
but in order to get a point you still
have to score a ball in the hoop
yeah i think that would have just made
it that much more improved
of feeling like you're actually watching
a basketball game
to a certain extent no matter how
ludicrous
and sci-fi it is you know well i almost
feel like having
just it like just a basketball game
grounds it in this weird sense of like
you've got all these other crazy
fantastical elements
and and then they're just playing a very
familiar game and i feel like there's a
comedic absurdity to glean from that
whereas this you know you're
in a crazy science fiction server you're
whizzing around between ip
planets and you're learning a new
version of not really basketball
and so yeah it's like everything is sort
of jacked
up to 11 in that sense and it would have
like that's where i started to feel like
there were six writers on this movie
because it does start to feel like a
medley of sketches which a cartoon a
looney tune
in a lot of ways is and so i'm not like
upset about that but when i think back
on it as an experience
weirdly the first space jam feels like
more of a
contained experience somehow well i
think i like the first half of this
movie more everything leading up to the
game yeah i actually like the first half
of this movie more
i really first bang but i i like the
game
of the original the original space jam
more than i like the game here
like as great as a lot of the effects
look some of it look really weird but
never really bother me because of what
the the property is or what like
don chito looks bizarre when he's like
cgi
like it looks weird like scorpion king
dwayne johnson died today
well you can see the displacement of the
budget because you get certain cg
effects that are so beautiful
and then you do get these like extras
who looked like they were dressed in an
afternoon
yeah oh yeah they half-assed after yeah
and there's so many shots
yeah i didn't do anything really that
creative with it it
got to the point where sometimes it was
a little distracting because i'm not
really paying attention to
because everyone's in focus for the most
part so you have like a shot of don
cheadle and he's talking
and then all these people who are who
just they don't look like the characters
are actually brought to life they just
look like extras
dressed in costumes so i find myself
like i'm not even paying attention to
who's the center of frame which is don
cheadle or lebron james
i'm just looking at who's in the
background and i kind of missed some of
what's being said
yeah because the background's becoming
distracting and it doesn't really feel
like lived in with the server verse
because it just looks like extras
in costumes like people who got clothes
at like a halloween shop or something
like that yeah
they look like the janky background
extras that don't get as much rendering
in like a video game or something
so yeah i would have liked the game to
feel weirdly that was the part i was
like i would have liked it to just feel
a little bit more like
because the first one does have the
crazy you know like breaking the pulp
fiction moment he has the long stretch
arm thing
um there's a lot of crazy silly [ __ ]
that happens in the first one yeah
um but i'm like well if you're gonna
dedicate like 30 to 40 minutes of the
game
in your movie now now i'm going to have
like a an actual criticism about what's
being done here
yeah and that i'm not really going to be
as passable on yeah
because while there's still enjoyable
moments in there i'm not gonna disregard
that like there's some cool looking
effects and there's some funny moments i
think don cheadle i think don cheadle
is probably the most surprising part too
of this to me because
he easily could have been the most
annoying thing about this film
and he managed to hit the right pitch
for this character
where it did feel like a character with
a with a purpose
and he he has this like really
you know uh he knows how to put on the
charm but you could feel
something a lot more malicious
underneath all that here and i like how
it sometimes comes out
and it comes out in the right moments i
i was surprised by don cheadle how he
actually built a character out of this
i mean you shouldn't be because he's a
great veteran actor he's one of like the
best of our time
yeah so he's this amazing actor but he
was good there and then he had some
really and
like from beginning to end he just had
certain lines that really cracked me up
absolutely yeah yeah and it's funny he
kept reminding me of that of
welcome to the internet just in that way
that he does
like appeal to dom in this very sort of
like no you're great and this is magical
what you can do and we're going to build
off of your idea
and in ways like i started to appreciate
the movie for things like that where i'm
like oh yeah this weird
personification of an internet algorithm
is a better performance than i was
expecting
and a weirdly kind of more interesting
villainous
entity than i was expecting in a way
especially for you know the relationship
dynamics that it plays on between the
father and son and the way that it
twists them and everything
and my favorite part in terms of like
doing the cartoony stuff
was when lebron first gets thrusted into
the the looney tunes
oh yeah because in the first space jam
especially
you know as people who grew up on it i'm
naturally gonna come because
it technically follows a lot of the same
beats as the first film yeah
it really does but the execution on
things are
is different which i was glad about like
for example when he gets thrown into the
looney tunes world he himself becomes a
looney tunes character i like how they
messed around with that where he doesn't
understand the anatomy of how any of
this
works and it keeps throwing him for a
loop i loved how he was a fan of the
looney tunes
and they really played into that like
that was hilarious
and yeah all the animation towards that
was gorgeous to look at i even like the
3d animation of them too
i think though what was missing for me
this first space jam movie as more as
much as it's more than
just looney tunes and it's more focused
because they're not dealing with the
warner brothers world and it is
i love how we're like seriously talking
about the series
it's not really dealing with the warner
brothers were just dealing more with
looney tunes and you got aliens
and then yeah you got like your bill
murray and your wayne knight uh wayne
knight
wayne yeah you got your bill murray and
your wayne knight you have those guys
there
but it still feels pretty focused on
that whereas the looney tunes
are kind of a thing here that i always
enjoyed
watching but i felt like the movie
itself didn't
really care about them as much as they
were like i thought they cared about
bugs bunny
but the tunes themselves it was there's
just so much mayhem going on that
it feels like looney tunes aren't are
included in this but it doesn't have the
looney tunes
it doesn't feel like a looney tunes film
or even a looney tunes
adjacent film you know what i mean and i
think that comes down to the fact of how
at least in the first space jam michael
jordan spends a lot of time
training them and bonding with them
before they get to the actual game so
there's a progression
in when they actually start winning you
know in the first one
and here you don't really get that
you know no and it hit me when they have
that
scene at halftime finally in the in the
locker room and i was sort of like oh
yeah that's part of what this movie has
been missing because
as much as i appreciate them not going
full bore with the server verse and
making everything about
ips like you know there's a good amount
of that but i felt like
for i like that they didn't ready player
won it i liked that they had the whole
lebron wants to put together like a
superman iron giant whoever else team
and then
eventually it's just the looney tunes
but it weirdly it felt like the universe
was much
less looney tunes and more than trying
to exist within this
greater server-verse narrative because
yeah in the original movie that is very
clear
what the stakes are if they lose the
game the looney tunes are gonna go to
[ __ ] mountain and be slaves forever
whereas this one i was like okay they're
gonna i guess disappear
if they lose because don cheadle hates
them
specifically for some reason and
i you know the and then the points don't
matter and yeah there is like a sort of
hodgepodge-ness of like there are a lot
of looney tunes characters or a lot of
really charming madcap
moments but weirdly the first movie knew
when to slow it down and when to make
them a bit more of an ensemble
or something like that and build on more
than just the kind of shtick
between uh you know your core athlete
character and the
tunes well yeah i mean they have a
pretty definitive main storyline here
which it's like the looney tunes are
just kind of
along for the ride in this one yeah or
they don't really need to
because in the first one they're it's
their mistake so they pull in michael
jordan
yeah and then here they're they're kind
of just there
you know like they've been brought along
but what i did like what they did with
it was they actually gave a rather
surprisingly emotional story for bugs
bunny here
that that actually um that was something
that i i felt a lot for
uh you know when he even though you know
he's gonna do the lebron move at the end
um you know when he is like being
deleted and stuff i really
cared in that moment i'm like bugs what
did you do and i'm like is this movie
killing off bugs buddy you know that's
all right
big shake-ups in the looney tunes
universe
so that emotional storyline i actually
thought was cool of a guy who's a bugs
bunny who feels like
alone and he's he's essentially like
doing his bugs bunny thing by tricking
uh lebron into just recruiting like
we're going to the worlds that lebron
wants to go to
to get the characters he wants but he
keeps walking out with the looney tunes
characters
you know so i thought they could have
added something there of
i've never even wanted you guys like
having a thing where there's a conflict
of like you tricked me bugs like having
it be something
there with them that way it still feels
like
a space jam sequel in the sense of it's
also
the looney tunes are like
the main supporting k like they they
technically are
um do you know what i'm getting at
though no they technically are because
they're
all working at the same goal and they're
all on the team together but yeah you
don't get those moments of
actual emotional team building because
that bugs wants
i like the idea of bugs wants to do this
just so he can get his friends and
family back
yeah that was cool but in terms of being
involved in the game they're just kind
of involved
in the game because they have to then
then at the last second they just throw
in
we need some stakes for them being here
they're going to be deleted yeah you
know they just introduced that like
right before the game like okay yeah
there's nothing there's no michael
secret stuff
or anything like that there's no yeah
and they try i like i like how they have
the moment
where lebron learns his lesson of
what he's doing wrong as a person as a
father in this
with the when with he's in the locker
room with with the tunes
and he realizes how he's treating the
tunes and trying to control the
situation
but because of its lack of focus i was
like well i didn't really
even get the sense that that was that's
what was going wrong in the game when
you were
like that you were not letting them let
loose and be that i'm like i didn't
really get that sense at all because
your
movie was not showing me how there was a
conflict of that happening
yeah yeah because most of the time i
feel like they could have maybe
benefited from splitting the time that
they
established once he arrives that oh
you've only got till the end of that
play clock to assemble and train your
team and i wish some of that had been
training
rather than going okay we finally got
the team and now we're gonna have an
argument and now the game's gonna start
you know
yeah like some yeah some kind of cause
that could have also contributed to the
fun in a way that focuses back in on the
looney tunes so that you're not still
mired in everything else wb owns you
know
yeah like i thought the two i thought
what they were going for was the tunes
were supposed to represent
the fun side that lebron lost as a child
because it became all about discipline
and so i thought what they were at least
attempting to do
here which they do by an outline
sort of like certain beats it's there
it's just there's so many missing scenes
that don't focus on this
is that the tunes are supposed to bring
out the childhood fun back with lebron
yeah and that's when he realizes
everything he's been doing wrong so in
order to win the game he has to embrace
the inner child within him again that
miss and all that fun
but you see i'm i i personally think i'm
i'm saying that better than what the
movie can
is did with most of their with the
scenes that where they could have done
that
well yeah because i thought they were i
thought they had an opportunity because
that's like the one of the early scenes
in the movie
isn't the game he's playing uh on his
little game boy or whatever when the
coach comes up isn't it a bugs buggy
game like yeah i thought they were gonna
make something about like oh yeah like i
love these cartoons growing up and yeah
that makes sense like oh that's he was a
fan of them
you know so that's i mean there were
things there that i could tell that's
what they
probably wanted to do more and i think
it would have made it more focused film
where you where all that other stuff is
you know cherry on top and a blast with
all the ips
but yeah i thought they they could have
done it and and that's the part where
i'm like oh you had something here where
because because the emotion and the
reason i guess i'm focusing on it
because the emotional [ __ ]
with him and his son worked for me in
this film so clearly having a little bit
of
extra heart and and i don't know if the
right word is weight but
nuance towards our main character that
he didn't get in the first one
surprisingly worked for me
and the thing that lacked was the
connection with the tunes characters
yeah and that seemed like a thing on
paper that they were
wanting to do and they kind of did it
but they didn't
really do it yeah this just happened
when the plot was saying it needs to do
that
yeah these are interestingly opposite
movies because
like this one improves on certain
aspects of the other and then
kind of loses its way in feeling like a
single coherent
film and it's yeah it's funny to me
because i saw this at the outset and i
was like six writers in a
hour and 55 minutes what is this gonna
be
and i feel like an hour like like the
time that they had is enough
to have done i i find it interesting
because i feel like they had enough time
to do what we've just been talking about
but also they managed to gracefully
express more than i was expecting
originally
yeah that makes sense well i think they
had a good grasp on the
on the visuals and the pacing of the
film which
uh like this felt like and
it still felt like a movie that was
assembled versus the
the other one which just felt like a
product
yeah like this definitely you know this
does feel
like it still feels like a product but
the more care was put into going how do
we actually make this kind of resemble a
real movie even though everyone knows
what we're doing
like i felt like the director was trying
to make a real movie and then he
probably had a lot of studio people
coming in
and then all the writers like whenever
you have that many writers that means
all right get it just
okay forget that guy he's not writing
anything we're gonna cut down a lot of
that
stuff all right forget this guys we're
gonna adr this guy
all that guy's scenes into one line and
then add a bunch more hygiene and
usually that many riders means the
studios are constantly hiring new
writers to do a new draft of this or
something like that so
um i don't know maybe it came down to
that too
but overall yeah
i enjoyed it yeah overall i enjoyed it
it was it was a little bit better than i
expected it to be
i would i would agree yeah so hey you
know
all things aside i have any criticisms i
think it's an enjoyable family film
and i like the i like the idea of family
seeing it and
you know because people were saying [ __ ]
like it's a family film but why does it
have all this stuff with like the horror
characters and everything i'm like
they're kind of just they're in the
background they're not
they're not even focused on you know you
know what i mean when they're
like for the absurdity of just like
they're just cheering
yeah yeah it was it's all i'm like i
don't know
of course i don't think kids yeah maybe
kids won't give a [ __ ] about that but
i like the idea of family seeing this
and with the message being of
parents encourage your children to be
who they want to be and don't try to
control
their dreams or passions you know if
anything let them
support them and then find the inner
child within you like there's some cool
themes
here where i'm like what are the themes
of the first one i can't even think of
something that
that was a lesson don't be enslaved for
an alien theme park
yeah i thought i liked what they did
here um so
i think it is a good family film and i
i'm weighing in against those
standards i'm weighing it in comparison
to the first one
and um yeah and i'm waiting against how
about how much worse it could have been
so all in all uh pretty much enjoyed it
but what did you guys think about the
film leave your thoughts down below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least let's do a
niraj krishnan my
looney tune from another
part of the country there was no rhyme
to do there but niraj
i hope you're doing well if we had to do
a space jam
in order to save the history not the
history the future
of the channel from being deleted by the
algorithm
i'd pull you into the game and i'd also
give you some sweet
powers like i would mix you with an
animal of some kind like a like a tiger
or
uh like a jellyfish or something so you
could zap people
and then you know think of all the
worlds we could go visit oh dude like
some of the
some of the uh less you know spectacular
but no less
great warner brothers films
uh such as mine
the niraj message to you
all right so um yeah i have this photo
where my hands are in my mouth like
there
and mirage messaged me saying uh just
the way you like it
with a smiley face
i've sent you so many messages you're
not on my spaceship anymore what were
you saying before i said any of that